It's okay to see such a weakened figure because I feel like Yasushi Koga is a solid human being
.
I know a village that has been destroyed
by an epidemic.  I want
it to be there, but I can't eat it, especially
because I can break it, my
mother,
it's money right now, look at
Mr. Kobayashi.
It may be difficult to find a medicine that cures only 8 sheets, but I
don't like it
. Did it increase by a little less than 4 minutes?
I'm glad I slept
in the
pool
I'm tired of what happened to the people
I went around the house
yeah I found a medicine that works well It's
okay and it
's weird so it's included
[Music]
I'll get it.
Yeah,
I heard it
[Music] It's
really saved. It's amazing. I don't know if I actually heard it, but if I see that,
I
'll say I heard it no matter what.
[Music]